please welcome from netflix's queer eye
jonathan van ness
hi how are you oh my god
how are you good long time no
see by the way did you get a haircut
i did i did i was like i just needed to
like
take some of that like 20 20 like length
off
well i actually have a hair company uh
that i'm
coming out with it's flower hair and
when i looked at
um i wanted to share this picture with
you can you see it
yes stun love the volume i can't get
enough
i want to put that picture up and then
put the
cover of your book up because i feel
like when i look at the
two images i just feel like our
personalities um have a lot in common
do you do you feel uh that it's some
spiritual mission in life to take care
of people to put
positivity out there to be a good person
i feel like my real mission has always
kind of been is that like if any of my
pain or like um any of my difficulties
or mistakes in my life if i can like
share that and ease that for others i
feel like that's kind of
that is like kind of where i feel more
of like a responsibility and if
joy is a part of that experience and
that's amazing
but i also one time like because i was a
yoga teacher for years and i um
still like you have a very active
practice it's like one of my favorite
stories
i was like late to teach a yoga class
because i'm six minutes late to do
everything that i ever do
and um i was like honking at this lady
because i was like oh my gosh you're
like literally going 25
like i gotta get around you queen i'm
gonna be like late to teach yoga and
then she ended up being in my class
after i'd like been honking at her
and i was like i was like 23 and i was
like
um so you know i still struggle like we
all have those moments where it's like
yes i can be like a patient loving
person but i also can be someone who's
like really like
so you know it's all like it's all a
spectrum i feel can i
ask like what gives you
the courage slash freedom
to share if i can help prevent
anyone else from feeling the the really
negative side effects of just like
rejecting
yourself and um you know i talk about in
my book a lot
like this idea of being normal and my
fear of not being normal like is
something that drove me
to such self-destructive behaviors and i
want i so just kind of want to help
people avoid that
um but not but i mean but also like i
still struggle with that
uh very same thing but my
self-destructive behaviors are like
name-searching myself on twitter or like
uh fighting with like a family member
who like i know i can't win with so it's
like
go to someone who you can win with the
courage is kind of necessity because i
know like what it's like to
suffer and feel you know really isolated
and be dealing with like addiction or
you know whatever and i i really want to
offer
some of the tools that i used to get to
where i am
um because it's just such like a lonely
place sometimes i think that
my whole life would be very different if
um like i was in an institution and they
broke in and like broke the story
on like the inquirer and it was
embarrassing and it was hard and it was
something i would have liked to have
preferably kept a secret but i wasn't
able to
but because i was sort of exposed if you
will
i chose to make that a moment of true
freedom and that i would never have to
be perfect or pretend to be perfect
again
and i love that you've put so many
things
out there especially in your book and
it's not easy to share those things
no i didn't understand how
it was going to open me up to
being like a strength for other people's
stories
and so and people sharing their stories
with me which i love that and i even
talk about this in the book but like
i just in in being open and honest it
was like
you know so many people were sharing
with me where they were in their stories
and so kind of going back into some of
those places
so often you know
being strong for that person but then
later on you're like
it's just it's so much to to take on and
be
and be that rock for people that at some
point you're like
i need to like sit on my couch and watch
like bob's burgers and cuddle with my
cat for like
three weeks because the reality of what
that costs
like your nervous system and again like
not to complain because like oh my god
like
i never would have dreamed to like have
a look at my shelves i can't believe i
have shelves like i really don't want to
complain because
i'm so grateful but i just think that
there was
kind of the reality of of my last few
years and becoming a public figure and
sharing all of that stuff it was like
oh my god i do believe in my heart
that by sharing your story
that you let other people know they are
not alone
and when people feel alone it is almost
very dangerous
and the fact that you did
help people make people feel
like they're going to get through this
this is not only happening to them
you are a human community i
commend you with all fibers of my being
and as someone who's had it all out
there it is an
ultimate form of freedom and the best
thing that maybe could even come out of
it is
positivity and optimism i guess at the
end of the day i think i just found out
why i
again i love both of those words so much
you